Of course I'm tough but I'm smart too I'm more smart than tough
What we ready for
The motivation watch it's half ten with believe nation. What's that believe nation? It's Evan
I believe in you and this channel is designed to be a part of your daily success routine
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and chew on today's lessons from a man who?
Went from growing up in Russia
Studying martial arts as a child and wrestling with a bear at age nine as a part of his training to becoming the undisputed UFC
lightweight
Champion, he's kebede the Margaux Medoff and here's my take on his top ten rules of success
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one be confident culinary's Bacon aim, I
Have big name, you know, and this is very good for paper. I'm confident, you know when I watch his eyes
I don't feel nothing. He's like drunk guy. You know, he's like drunk
I feel he's like his face is like like this, you know in nervous he drunk and
he little bit white, you know, it's like
When you say to Danny no, no, I'm not gonna touch him
I wanna watch his eyes and I think I'm here and I watch his eyes. I feel nothing I
Swear to God, I feel like he nervous he drunk how we're gonna fight with me with me
25 minute
This is not Nate Diaz or this is not Eddie Alvarez or Josie hell that this is a completely different fighter
You know, if we're not stop it you have to kill me
This guy have to him if I see him if I keep seeing I'm gonna keep going. I'm gonna keep go forward
Don't rush stay relaxed, you know, give him very good
you know like
Crazy time inside the cage rule number two always be prepared
You know like if you cannot beat
Anyone in this division like max Holloway the acquaintance or 20 Ferguson, you know like you make wait
You already?
Do very good training camp? You ready?
And now if you're gonna talk about all these guys difference at least the guy, you know
I need like couple month for training for this guy how you can call yourself champion if you're champion if you wanna be champion
undisputed undefeated
You have to come compete anybody today's our mother still Ramadan day, you know today were fasting so now
I was like 5 p.m. Almost and
After two and a half hour, we're gonna eat
Who can it?
Today this today is Sunday - you know we come here like almost like ten people resting each other, you know, and
It's very important. Very important
Stay ready. Stay in shape
You know because anytime you can call me and say hey
You gotta fight
To a month three months and that's why I have to be they have to stay ready rule number three be smart
So if the shoes on the other foot if the roles were reversed you wouldn't take this fight on six days notice
You think it's crazy for him to do this for me? I never take this. No why why anything this fight?
I need eight weeks trying hard
Last one week make weight and go to the world because when I go to the world, I have to know hey
I'm ready or no, because like
Six days, you cannot be you cannot training. You have to cut weight all six days, you know and
This is not about oh and tough. I'm gonna show you guys how I'm tough. Of course, I'm tough, but I'm smart, too
I'm more smart than tough. And
People watching my record and they think oh this guy tough. This is not about that. This is about mine
This is about how you think when you fight like
You know like this is about everything. You know why I need take some fight like
if you have to give me fight I
Try no injures. Come here
Make weight fight
But other stuff I don't care like if your self problem, this is UFC problem
This is that's why my name is Habib other name is you see you know
I
care about my legacy UFC already have his legacy know like UFC is the
Biggest organization right now in the world like it's gonna be without you see or know people gonna remember this
Like I want people remember my name like undisputed undefeated
You see lightweight champion and why I need take like six days before fight like some fights
I never do this rule number four play your game
He's talked about your brother. He's called your father a coward. He has made fun of where you live
Are you going into this fight angry at all? Mmm
David
I can control my emotional. You know, he can he can say worry what he want, you know like
When some hog alcohol you guys talking about something people don't care about this
I don't care about what are you talking about? Because I know who I am
I know my friends. So my family know my clothes people know who I am and 100 Sam. I'm sure he knows too
But he just want to make me nervous
But it's okay. This is part of the his game and
Of course I'm a little bit angry but
You have to control your emotion, you know, when I go to the cage I'm gonna control and I have planned
Don't rush stay relaxed
Go forward and make him tired after I can do whatever. I want rule number five work hard. I feel I have energy
I feel I have to improve something and that's why we come here. We sent a nice message each other
Hey, let's go tomorrow 3:00 p.m. We have to train we have to Train everybody and
Some people say I'm tired today is Sunday today is race day
But some people say, okay, we're gonna come because we have somebody have fight after one month
Somebody have fight after one and a half month and you know
That's why everybody we have to turn if you fight please come to come Jimmy train and only hard work
You know, we have only one way
It's like you can't wait
I
Remember all the time come from here running and sprint here ten times and go back to running
Its take like maybe
25 30 minute every day before I go to school I do this training
Running here sprint to this mountain and go back home
Drills home resting drills a little bit lifting and go to the school. It's my like every day I do this
And all the time when I come to village I turn there all the time come here running around
Tama do sprints rule number six be a good role model what I don't like when too much people
Know yes, because too many young
Young guys like polo oz follow him
And I can I don't want to be a bad example for young generation. I do want this
I do understand, you know, we cannot be bad people for young generation people. Of course, you try to promote this fight make honey
Yeah, but like end of the day you have to think about the young generation age
too many people watch on us and you know
And to be a role model, we really should just be saying I don't talk about him
I know I wanna talk about me. Okay, I wanna be good one, but I know it's very hard
Nobody's perfect
Rule number seven surround yourself with greatness. I've not thought these guys like one year two years Turner's
I know this has more than 15 years
No, we stay together like science when I'm beginning my amateur career where everybody be here with my father and you know
it's like my brother's my friends like
Oh here
Files, you know we keep training with you competition
Always like this
I
Don't have a lot. I don't like this. I'm little bit scared about this, you know, they're long
we are not like because like
When you're living you need someone with you always
If you make mistake, they have to say hey you make mistake
You have to become
a
different way
Like wherever that is women and everybody make mistake this way Allah say hey
You guys have to be always together like drama, you know, it's very important. This is not my French friend
Listen, listen about five
Rule number eight be respectful what caused you to to jump over the cage and indigo after Connors team?
It's off guys. How are you?
First of all, I want to say sorry to athletic commission, Nevada. Sorry to Vegas
I know this is not my best side. You know, this is not my best side. You know, I'm humor bin and
Like I know understand how people can talk about I jump on the cage
You know, what about he talk about my religion he talk about my country
He talk about my father. He come to Brooklyn and he broke bass
He almost killed couple people worried about this worried about this why people talk about I jump over the cage
Why people still talk about this? Like I don't understand I am respect my father teach me
Hey, you have to be always respectful my old team where I'm training, California seven years
Everybody know who I am media a little bit change MMA. This is a respect sport. You know, this is not trash-talking sport
This is recipe. So like I told you before guys, I wanna change this game. I don't wanna people talk about like
Opponents talk about his father like like religion you you cannot talk about religion
You cannot take about nation, you know guys, you cannot talk about this stuff
And you know, this is for me is very important rule number nine help others
Like in there
Say hands habit, I
Control this everything here. You have to give me money you said this?
Small guy it's very small guy. I tell me what you control
Like about parking like everything and he's like 10 years old his ears like smash like crazy
You know, like if he looked like he training right here he hewed he resting like last 20 years
You know, he said please you have to give me money because I control everything now you come here
You park your car you have to pay me money. I
Go crazy with it. I live like crazy. I said, okay how how much I have to give?
It's like $10, you know
I said you too expensive you have to be come down like maybe five six dollars my 10 goes too much for you
They say hey, my mother is sick. You have to pay me I said, okay, I'm gonna tell you
It's great
Dagestan like mother Dagestan life and rule number 10. The last one before a very special bonus clip is
wrestle with bears
I've got a special bonus clip around how to stay humble that I think you're gonna really enjoy
But before that it's time for the three-point landing question
It's time to move from just watching another video to actually taking action in your life or your business
And if you're feeling bold answer these questions in the comments below. Here we go. Number one
How can you surround yourself with greatness number two?
What's the thing that helps you feel the most confident and number three, how can you start your day every day with it?
Never know what's gonna happen tomorrow and
You have to stay loyal all the time with your team with
your coaches
With your like with everybody who close with you, you know, sometimes like when you win belt
With the belt coming like a lot of attention
a lot of money like like
crazy stuff a lot of crazy stuff and I don't want this bill change me, you know, I
Want to stay focused I wanna after Ramadan beginning training and come back this year and they fed this title
you know like I'm a little bit worried about this belt because
sometimes you think all now like your UFC champion like lot of stuff but
I'm a little bit scared about this. I don't wanna change. I want to be same habit like before built and after belt and
This is not about me this is about all people around me raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is
that
that people need passion and
Not one drop of my self-worth depends on your it's supposed to mean
If you like this video check at the top 10 I did on Conor McGregor, I think you'll like it
The link is right there next to me continue to believe and I'll see you there
This is what gives me energy saying I'm gonna do something say it putting it out there
For the world to see I mean don't out doing it